today we're going to be speaking with
Thomas Gabor who's a criminologist and
author of five books on gun violence
including American Carnage shattering
the myths that fuel gun violence Tom
really appreciate your time uh today
thanks for joining me my pleasure to be
with you David so I mean let's just
start with a very simple premise and see
if there's anything to it some of those
in the United States who don't want to
see any additional gun safety
regulations or laws put in place say
they wouldn't do anything to reduce
shootings anyway is that a claim that we
can actually debunk with with data do
gun safety regulations reduce shootings
uh certain ones do and uh you know I
just came across another report today
that showed for example that red States
states that are uh run mostly by
government a governor who's a Republican
or a republican
legislature which tend to have weaker
gun laws have much higher gun mortality
rates so there's a lot of evidence that
first of all there's a correlation
between gun ownership and gun mortality
there's a tendency there's gun ownership
levels go up in the states and there's
huge variations there uh they there
tends to be an increase in gun mortality
or gun deaths and gun homicides as well
so and as well we see when we rate
states in terms of the weakness or
strength of the gun laws the stronger
the gun laws the lower gun mortality
tends to be what can you give a couple
of examples of the types of regulations
that are effective and then maybe a
couple of examples of the ones that
maybe aren't so much
okay well a good question first of all
I've studied gun licensing around the
world and that requires a much thorough
more thorough background check than we
do here in the United States where you
have interviews with law enforcement you
have reference checks and so forth and
those countries tend to do a whole lot
better than we do and we see some states
that have some kind of owner licensing
such as Connecticut that have done
better than other states and they've
seen gun homicides go down another one
is storage safe storage seems to make an
enormous difference or what we also call
child access prevention laws so when we
have consequences
for people not securely storing their
guns in terms of legal consequences that
seems to make a difference because for
example uh we've seen many School
shooters these young men uh who've
either often obtained their guns not
always but often from the home or the
home of a relative and these guns were
not secured now as far as what doesn't
work uh because you know it's only in
the last few years that the federal
government has been able to conduct
research because there's been an attempt
by allies of the gun lobby to stop all
research in this area we hear a lot
about Universal background checks and I
like to make a clarification there
because what that means is that and this
is what people are seeking that every
individual buys a gun
has to have a background check so today
we have this you might call a loophole
where if you buy on the private Market
you buy through the internet or from gun
stores you don't need to go undergo a
background check if you not bought from
a licensed dealer so I'm all for that
however the background check system also
in my view is broken but if all we do is
expand background checks to all sales
it's not sufficient because they're
enormous problems with the system itself
it's a two-minute check of three FBI
databases and so we've had people like
the Parkland shooter who showed all
kinds of disturbing signs but because he
didn't have a criminal felony record he
was able to buy his AR-15 legally from a
gun store so we need the analogy I use
is you know we pretty well have
Universal checks when we get on the
plane everybody gets checked
but the second question is not just does
everybody get checked but how good is
that detection right it lets through a
lot of guns and explosives then you can
check everybody uh but it's not
sufficient so what I'm saying here is
the background the quality of the
background check system itself has to be
improved I don't believe to just
expanding background checks is
sufficient what about ideas uh like
restricting the ability to purchase
certain Firearms to individuals of a
certain age so maybe if you're under 25
certain Firearms would not be legally
purchasable I mean with all these things
you can always say well then that person
will figure out how to get that firearm
illegally but it's like maybe they won't
some of them won't
right and you know that argument that
you know criminals will always be
criminals and it's such a gross over
simplification yeah you know and
therefore we can't stop somebody who's
determined to get a gun well first of
all a lot of gun violence isn't
committed isn't premeditated it's
spontaneous so if you happen to be
carrying around the gun and you get into
a fight or a road rage incident you're
more likely to pull that gun but the
other thing is that if we use that logic
we get rid of all laws because you can't
stop
all a molestation the rape or homicide
and so forth so uh but some people are
deterred and you make it more difficult
because what's easier than allowing
somebody who's shown some Disturbing
Behavior to simply because they don't
have a criminal record on file
especially a felony record to just walk
in and purchase a gun in two minutes
right uh you know and they could be also
very aggravated angry about something so
uh I think though the age issue that you
mentioned would be helpful because we do
have quite a few people are committing
gun violence
after that it becomes much more
difficult legally because a person can
argue in court that well I'm you know
I'm old enough to go fight for the
country I'm old enough to vote you know
so uh you know you don't have the right
to kind of abridge my rights and Tom we
lost it we lost Europe we lost your
audio just for a second where I think
what you were saying was it's easier to
restrict based on a based on age before
people are 18 was that the argument you
were making but that these in between
ages can be tough legally
yeah though you know 18 to 21 I mean
that's passed in a number of states and
it passed in Florida as well before the
legislature tried to uh repeal that yeah
um so 18 to 21 I say is probably as high
as you can go got it uh and there are
people challenging that as well
saying that they can vote they could
serve the country at 18 and so forth so
they should be able to purchase a gun
but leaving the legal arguments alone I
think 18 to 21 certainly those are some
of the most active years for people who
commit gun violence so raising that age
can be helpful
I want to talk about the issue of mental
health and there are so many aspects to
this you know on the one hand
colloquially speaking without diagnosing
anyone
and when I think about a mass shooting
it seems that we would say anyone who
gets to a point where this is something
they would go and do
they're probably quote mentally ill in
some way because no quote sane person
would do that this is a very simplistic
thing to say but in some sense many of
us would say no sane person who's
emotionally regulated and whatever would
ever commits such an act so in a sense
certainly mental health is a component
but what do we really mean when we say
that are we talking about somebody who
has anxiety and sees a therapist what
what is it exactly that we're trying to
get at when we talk about mental health
how do you believe the mental health
layer should be applied to the gun
safety regulations layer
well we call it the mental illness Dodge
there's a world of difference between
saying that somebody has a severe mental
illness like schizophrenia uh bipolar
disease psychosis or something like that
and only four percent of people who
commit violent crimes in the country
have a severe mental illness now what
you're talking about is often
individuals who are agitated
in fact one of the frightening
statistics in this country is that over
20 million individuals have serious
anger issues they're people who can have
a short trigger if you wish and are
quick to anger have impulsive anger
issues and also own guns this is a much
bigger problem so yes I mean when you're
talking about somebody who commits a
mass shooting or even a a shooting of an
one individual that they're agitated
they're angry but we all get angry at
times and so there's a world of
difference between somebody suffering
from major mental illness and they're
usually more of a danger to themselves
in terms of suicides and they're more
likely to be victims of crime we see
that with the homeless some of the
homeless mentally ill who are victimized
to different cities but they're much
less of a concern unless they also had
in addition to a serious mental illness
A History of Violence I'd be more
concerned with people who are ready
at a moment's notice to deploy guns
against Intruders or people who may be
an intruder you know these recent
incidents where somebody took a turn in
the wrong driveway and was shot at and
somebody else who knocked on the wrong
door I'm more concerned about all these
people now because they've been sold the
gun lobbies narrative that you're safer
with a gun in the home and you know the
gun lobby has done a lot to stoke
people's fears and they're ready they
have 40 percent now of people have guns
in the home have the guns loaded and
accessible that's what I'm worried about
and if they also have a short trigger
and they're also afraid very very afraid
uh because this fear has been stoked for
decades now I'm more concerned about
those individuals because the guns are
at the ready and they're primed to
commit an act of violence yeah you're
getting to now going Beyond mental
illness into a cultural component and
one of the things that is different in
the United States than in many other
countries where I've spent time is that
there is a gun culture which I describe
it as it sees Firearms as a more valid
way to resolve interpersonal issues
frustrations political issues ETC which
access aside and of course we have to
talk about access access aside I don't
see in a lot of the other countries
where I've spent time is this intangible
cultural difference a reality in the
United States
well you know this is what we take on
one of the myths we take on in our book
American Carnage because in reality uh
first of all there is no
all-encompassing gun culture in the
United States we have entire regions
like New England where you have gun
ownership levels in certain areas of
only 15 to 20 percent right only a third
of American adults are gun owners uh now
uh if you're talking about a minority of
individuals who you might say have a gun
fetish in stock a large arsenal of guns
we're talking about maybe what we call
the super owners who are six percent of
the American population and they own
two-thirds of all the guns wow that
doesn't make them all dangerous at all
but these are the people who have more
of a gun fetish if you want to call it
that and some of them are just
collectors but the vast majority of the
population isn't like that but let me
tell you what's changed is in 1977 the
National Rifle Association got taken
over by a very extremist group of people
and they have now spent over 40 years
trying to convince Americans that if you
arm yourself in the home and carry guns
you're going to be a lot more safe the
other thing they did is because with the
decline of hunting and the end of the
draft and the military draft was where
many people were introduced to guns and
the increasing urbanization of the
country there was a real crunch on the
gun industry so they started pushing
this Narrative of self-protection so
this is only about 40 years old this
narrative that we should all have guns
we're safer with guns in the home
carrying guns in fact in the
1800s most of the states banned the
carrying of concealed firearms so we
actually in the United States have a
history going back to the revolutionary
period of regulating Firearms even
having citizens forming a militia and
asking them once a year to show up at
the Town Square to show why the guns you
have and those guns could be seized by
the militia if there was an attack on
the country or some Revolution to put
down so we've had a history actually the
old west you had gun ordinances but it's
more recently the last 40 years that
we've departed from that history and
that what you call a gun culture is
really an attempt by extremists and the
gun lobby to promote the idea of the
Armed citizenry being safer but we see
that it's nothing you know it's so far
from the truth and what we're seeing is
the opposite more mass shooting more gun
deaths children now the number one cause
of death of Americans up to 19 is is
gunfire and so forth so things have
really moved in in the opposite
direction from what they're claiming
the book is American Carnage shattering
the myths that fuel gun violence we've
been speaking with Thomas Gabor
criminologist really appreciate your
time and insights today thank you David
it's been a pleasure